Just for me, in terms of what's happening in.
In farming. Right.
There's a lot of talk about environmentalism
and how farmers practices are not doing anything for the environment.
My own viewers. There's a lot of radical greens out there.
There's a demonization of family.
In my view. Farmers work out of fantastic custodians of the land.
I think farmers are very proactive. Yeah.
They're very good to adapt,
to change. And, like,
there's one certainty going forward
is that there is going to be a lot of change.
Yeah. You're running a business that has to adapt, right?
But the reality is that while you're adapting,
you don't want to be demonized.
Yeah. And look,
one of the things that we have to see
is we need to see an increase in CAT payments as we go forward.
Carbon sequestration happens in the site,
and you're doing that, right?
I mean, you should get credit for that.
We have to maintain the nitrous interrogation as one, right?
I mean, you know,
if we go back to 1 70, we're going to see a decimation of the industry.
Protection of the nitrous segregation.
The extension of that interrogation will be a priority for me.